hello it's eight o'clock this is sky
news breakfast these are our top stories
here this morning
misery for travellers as tens of
thousands of workers walk out in the
sixth national rail strike
i'm here at a quiet houston station
where just one in five trains are
operating across the network today
accusations of positive discrimination
by the raf as leaked emails claim it
artificially inflated its diversity
numbers
if in the past there is evidence that
somebody has deliberately or otherwise
been engaged in positive discrimination
that is against diversity laws and we
will be investigating that and we'll
make sure people are held to account
a holiday from reality michael gove
criticizes liz trust over her tax plans
and endorses rishi sunak in the tory
leadership race
calls for nationwide caps on rental
prices as rents reach all-time highs up
and down the country
[Music]
and coming up later in the program we'll
be joined by all five members of steps
as they celebrate a quarter of a century
in the spotlight
also ahead in the sport britain's
anthony joshua weighed in 23 pounds
heavier than champion alexander usyk for
tonight's heavyweight world title
rematch live on sky box office
and coming up at quarter two we'll take
you through the morning papers with the
journalists and broadcaster bedisha
mamata and the editor of spiked magazine
tom slater
[Music]
hello a very good morning to you
passengers on britain's railways are
facing another day of disruption as tens
of thousands of rail workers strike over
pay and working conditions it's the
second walkout in three days and the
sixth of the summer with unions and the
government reportedly still some
distance apart in agreeing a settlement
well more than 40 000 railway workers
who are members of the rmt union are
walking out members of the transport
salaried staffs association and united
unions are also taking part in
industrial action
and because the strike involves network
rail staff all train operators will be
affected in some way
network rail says only about 20
of britain's rail network will be open
and some parts of the country will have
no trains at all services that do run
will start later and finish earlier than
usual
and it's not just the rail passengers
facing disruption today more than 1600
london bus drivers also going on strike
well our correspondent sabah chaudhary
is at houston station in central london
for us this morning so supper another
day of strikes
is any progress being made between the
two sides
good morning anna not quite yet so this
is day three of strike action this week
and the message uh remains loud and
clear from those at the picket line
they're calling for better pay working
conditions and job security and this is
what they're asking from their employers
now they're not the only ones that are
walking out they are joined today by
tens of thousands of other union members
who are also calling for the same thing
for the same protections for them and
for their families now we are seeing
reduced services across the country
today about one in five trains so to
around 20
of trains are operating today from 6 30
this morning to 7 30 in the evening and
this includes cross-country services and
in central london just yesterday it was
almost the the travel industry was to a
standstill uh here in the capital and
that's because the tubes most of the
tubes weren't operating and the same
went for the majority of buses and that
is the same issue that we are seeing
today now uh earlier sky news spoke to
eddie dempsey the assistant general
secretary of the rmt about the latest on
the negotiations and this is what he
said
we've had some
improved positions from network rail
which is one of the companies we're in
dispute with today
but so far we've had no offers of any
kind or substance
from the 14 train operating companies
that we're in dispute with so we're in a
very difficult time at the moment
our members are suffering in the cost of
living crisis they're facing a threat of
redundancies
um and it seems that the minister is
hell-bent
on escalating the dispute and trying to
make things more difficult for our
people so we're in a very difficult
place
so what he said there about the
transport secretary grant chaps being
hell bent that's him taking from what
the minister himself said uh his words
that the trade unions are hell-bent on
causing
misery to society and to the wider
public now i spoke to mick lynch the
general secretary of the rmt earlier who
has been uh the face of
these strikes and he was saying that the
future
of
his members lies with them
and it's something that is they are very
concerned about for the moment
saber thanks very much indeed for that
now sky news has obtained leaked emails
that suggest the royal air force has
artificially inflated its diversity
numbers to hit government targets for
female and ethnic minority recruits it's
alleged that raf recruitment officers
were directed to prioritize the
placement of women and ethnic minorities
on training courses last year well the
armed forces minister james heapey says
it's not true that the recruitment of
white men was paused but if there's any
evidence of that then the people
responsible would be held to account
sky's security and defense editor debra
haynes has this exclusive report
attracting a diverse workforce is a
priority for air chiefs like society at
large
adverts such as this one is a form of
positive action to draw different faces
into what's traditionally been a largely
white male profession
but defense sources allege the diversity
push may have prompted some positive
discrimination that could impact uk
defenses if some white men are being
unfairly disadvantaged
that would be illegal and a minister
insisted it wouldn't be tolerated
no minister in the mod and no chief of
any service
gets to break the law and so if there is
evidence of positive discrimination
the people responsible for that will be
held vigorously to account the raf has
been in the spotlight this week after
sky news revealed its head of
recruitment had resigned over what
defense sources said were impossible
diversity targets
the sources said she'd quit in protest
following an effective pause on making
job offers to white men in favor of
ethnic minorities and women yet the
minister said the pause was for all new
entrants to allow air chiefs to explore
whether they could use positive action
to boost diversity levels what is
definitely not true is the recruitment
of white men has in any way being paused
it's definitely not true that women and
ethnic minorities are being loaded onto
courses now whilst white men are not but
a former fast jet pilot released this
internal email on his youtube channel
unless
fame and female
tim davies claimed it showed in 2020 the
raf appeared to be willing to hold back
white men from taking an aptitude test
as part of selection though the raf said
the instruction was quickly corrected
this is positive discrimination against
against someone because of an immutable
characteristic which we know in this
case happens to be their skin color and
and their sex it's white men it's
indefensible what's happening right now
within the service in 2015 the
government set a target for all the
armed forces to hit 10
ethnic minority recruits and 15 female
recruits by 2020
the raf alone stretched the target for
women recruits to 20 within that time
frame
in march 2021 the service proudly
announced it had met the targets
but the armed forces own diversity
statistics don't show how these figures
were achieved they described the female
inflow as 18.3 percent and don't provide
a breakdown for ethnic minorities the
raf said the discrepancy is because its
internal data excluded women choosing to
rejoin
leaked documents give a further insight
into how the diversity targets were hit
in the year 2020 to 2021 with sources
alleging women and ethnic minorities
were brought forwards onto training
courses early to boost the statistics
one file revealed the recruitment force
continues to prioritize female
candidates for customer relationship
management
another document sets out how the
bringing forwards of some women into
training courses early had impacted the
following 12 months targets it read the
pipeline remains depleted of women
candidates following the advanced
loading of these candidates in the
fourth quarter of the previous year
an raf spokesperson said all its
recruitment action was legal and said
operational effectiveness is of
paramount importance and no one is
lowering the standards to join the royal
air force the raf recruits for many
professions and like the rest of the
armed forces is determined to be a force
that reflects the society it serves to
protect
the royal air force has a well-earned
reputation for operational excellence
that's founded on the quality of our
people we will always seek to recruit
the best talent available to us
no one's disputing the raf's proud past
but there are internal voices who are
worrying about the forces future
debra haynes sky news
with 16 days to go until we find out the
winner of the tory leadership race rishi
sunak has picked up the support of a big
name in the party michael gove writing
in the times the former leveling up
secretary accused the front-runner liz
truss of taking a holiday from reality
with her tax plans our political
correspondent liz bates has the latest
michael gove is what you would call a
big beast of british politics he's been
around a long time he's held a lot of
high profile senior positions cabinet
positions
education secretary justice secretary
more recently he was secretary of state
for leveling up he's also
run for the conservative leadership
himself
a couple of times so his opinion holds a
lot of weight within his party and
within westminster and in this article
for the times what michael gove uh says
setting out his reasons for this
decision first of all he says liz
truss's campaign has been a holiday from
reality and that her tax cuts will put
the stock options of ftse 100 executives
before the poorest turning to rishi soon
out what he says is that as prime
minister he would put the strength of
the state at the service of the weakest
and provide millions of people with the
support they need during the cost of
living crisis the other thing that's
quite surprising in this article is that
he also touches on his own career and
says that he will be stepping back
from frontline politics it may be quite
surprising to some of his colleagues
love him or
loathe him as i said he's had a lot of
big jobs he's been around a long time
there are many people within his party
that are loyal to him he will certainly
leave behind him
a legacy at the top of british politics
when it comes to that endorsement though
the question of course is will this make
an impact liz trust at this point is
really pulling so far ahead of in the
polls uh it's really starting to look
like maybe she can't be beaten so no
doubt a big intervention from a very big
name in british politics but at this
stage it might just be too little too
late
well with experts expecting the energy
price cap to soar by 75 percent when
it's announced by the regulator ofgem on
friday it's said to be a significant
week in the cost of living crisis well
now labour is pledging to review how the
minimum wage is decided so that in its
words
it pays
pay at least covers the cost of living
so let's speak to labour's shadow
employment rights and protections
minister justin mattis who joins me now
justin madison thanks for joining us so
tell us exactly what you're proposing
with the minimum wage then
well it was one of the great
achievements of the last labour
government to introduce the minimum wage
in the first place but as as we've seen
over the last decade or so
the increases in it have not kept up
with the cost of living and that's got
us to this crunch point now where
inflation's sparring out control and
wages are lagging far behind and there
are about five million people in this
country who are in work but are in
poverty and we've got to change that
cycle so what we're suggesting is that
the low pay commission whose job is to
set the minimum wage well in future be
able to take into account the cost of
living as one of their considerations so
that in the longer term we get to a
point where the minimum wage is actually
a wage people can afford to live on and
pay all their bills
what will actually change because as i
understand that the low pay commission's
remit requires it to consider the link
to
average wages as well as wider economic
conditions already when it makes its
decision on on what the minimum wage
should be
well it does consider those things but
this is a very specific request to look
at the cost of living so actually what
people get in their pocket is uh
reflected in terms of what they're
actually
being required to pay out and uh we know
don't we that
wages are far behind the cost of living
at the moment and and clearly
something's got to change because uh we
can't have the situation in this country
forevermore where people are in
full-time work but are having to go to
food banks are struggling from month to
month to meet their bills because that's
not a sustainable way for us to grow as
a country we want the economy to grow we
want people to benefit from that and one
of the best ways to do that is to make
sure that the low pay commission and
future will be able to consider the
minimum wage as part of their cost of
living measures
okay so so put a figure on it for us can
you what should the minimum wage be
under those kind of calculations now
well
we're not going to be setting the figure
it's the low pay commission's job to do
that which is what they do at the moment
give us a ballpark then are you saying
that it should rise by 10 because
inflation is uh 10 at the moment
well look we're in a very turbulent uh
economic situation aren't we inflation
is is possibly going as high as 14 early
next year we're probably a couple of
years away from a general election so
i'm not going to sit here today and give
you figures that will probably be out of
date very shortly what we're trying to
do with this proposal though is get out
get our minimum wage on a long-term
sustainable footing that actually
ensures that those cost of living issues
are baked into the considerations in
future we want people to be able to work
we want people to be able to pay their
bills when they're in work and i think
at the moment that simply isn't
happening
so should the fact that rents are
different for example in different parts
of the country be taken into
consideration if you really are looking
at the cost of living should there be
regional differences in the minimum wage
if you're going to fully take into
account how much people have to spend to
live
well we we want a a national wage to be
to be set we think it should apply
across the whole of the uk of course in
different parts of the country there
will be different cost pressures and
actually we we would expect employers to
be reflecting that in their uh pay
packets as well but actually at the
moment wherever you live in the country
the minimum wage is simply not enough to
allow people to pay their bills which is
why we've got this cost of living crisis
so really what we want to
do is try and break that cycle and make
sure that work genuinely pays
so no regional variations even though
the cost might be different in different
areas just to confirm that
no no what we we're looking to set a
national
rate here as the national minimum wage
applies at the moment and we would we
would expect that uh to be able to uh
deal with cost of living pressures
throughout the uk i think everyone would
agree that a huge number of people are
really affected by the rising cost of
living but but businesses are as well
aren't they and there are lots of small
businesses who are really concerned
about energy prices for example going up
they don't have the benefit of having a
cap on on those prices
are you concerned at all that if they
have to pay higher wages in terms of of
the minimum wage that could push some
over the edge
well uh one of the announcements we made
earlier this week on the cost of living
was that there would be support
available for uh business as well
up to a billion pounds but actually what
we're what we're trying to say as part
of the low commission pay commission's
room is that they would also still be
able to look at the things that they
look at at the moment which is the
general economic conditions and they
take evidence from businesses about
their cost pressures so those things
would still be part of the mix but in
the longer term actually paying staff
a proper wage is actually beneficial for
businesses it creates a level playing
field it gets more money in people's
pockets it actually improves recruitment
and retention so in the longer term it
would definitely be a win-win situation
for businesses as well
and finally just before i let you go
another rail strike today will you be
joining a picket line at all
well
i've been on picket lines in the past uh
and i'll be on picket lines again in the
future but actually whether one person
is on a picket line or not is is
probably not the real issue because the
one person actually who needs to take
some action today to try and resolve
this is grant shaped and all we're
afraid we've heard from him is
provocation and aggressive language
which is doing nothing to
get the compromise that is needed to end
this dispute i would urge him to sit
down with the rmt or give his
negotiators the authority to sit down
with the rmt to actually get this uh
dispute resolved
you say it doesn't make a difference if
one person's on the picket line but if
they are a shadow minister showing
support for the workers that might make
a difference to them
well look look we we will always have uh
great solidarity and affinity with the
trade union movement and we will
absolutely defend uh people's right to
strike
and i'm sure some some members of
parliament will be will be representing
uh their constituents on picket lines
today but actually uh it's a distraction
from uh the real issue here which is the
government's intransigence and trying to
prolong this dispute rather than resolve
it and really what we should be saying
to people rather than having this debate
about picket lines is really what are
the government actually going to do to
try and resolve this dispute that's what
the members of the rmt want that's what
the rail passengers want that's what the
whole country wants and really the
pressure and the questions have to be on
the government what are they going to do
to resolve this dispute because they're
at the moment they only seem to be
prolonging it
okay and the government of course says
between the employers and the unions
it's a conversation we'll have many
times i'm sure in in the days and weeks
ahead but justin madison we appreciate
your time today thanks very much indeed
so let's take a look now at some of the
morning's other stories now and the
government's insultancy service has said
it won't start criminal proceedings
against p o ferries over the company's
decision to fire nearly 800 workers in
march and then hire cheaper staff the
sackings sparked criticism from trade
unions and politicians leading the
government to cancel a contract with the
company
in somalia at least 12 people have been
killed after armed attackers took
control of a hotel in the capital
mogadishu emergency services told
reuters news agency that gunfire and two
car bombs hit the hotel yesterday
evening and that a siege is underway
the al-qaeda-linked al-shabaab group has
reportedly claimed responsibility for
the attack
finland's prime minister says she's
taken a drugs test for her own legal
protection after videos emerged of her
at a party with friends in a private
home
speaking at a news conference in
helsinki sana marin defended her actions
and insisted she'd never used illegal
drugs
let's take a check now what the
weather's up to
warm memories wherever you
[Music]
the
go
sponsored by qatar airways
well the weekend will bring fresher
conditions with showers or longer spells
of rain especially in the north and west
southeastern parts are mainly fine but
there are some showers elsewhere with
more general heavy rain in the windy
north coastal gales are possible in the
far northwest a narrow band of heavy
rain and gusty winds will largely clear
the rest of scotland and northern
ireland during the morning while
spreading across more of ireland
brighter more showery conditions will
follow on
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
hello very good morning you're watching
sky news breakfast our top stories here
this morning widespread disruption is
expected as more than 40 000 railway
workers strike over pay and conditions
sky news has obtained leaked emails that
suggest the royal air force has
artificially inflated its diversity
numbers to hit government targets for
female and ethnic minority recruits
and former cabinet minister michael gove
has endorsed rishi soon act to be the
next conservative party leader and
accused the foreign secretary liz truss
taking a holiday from reality
now england rugby player rosie galligan
is among other celebrities supporting a
charity campaign to look out for your
maids and raise awareness of meningitis
for those heading off to university this
autumn
and rosie joins me now to talk about her
own experience with meningitis so very
good morning to you rosie thanks so much
for coming on so you contracted
meningitis
was it 2019 tell us a little bit about
what happened to you
yeah so i was just getting ready for a
rugby game um in september 2019 and all
of a sudden just went really heavy um
my brain was trying to sleep but my body
was just so irritable and ended up being
really sick and the next morning woke up
with a bit of a rash on my leg and my
mum rang the non-emergency services and
just explained kind of what was
happening and they blew lighted me in
and i was in quarantine then for the
next 10 days um pretty much unable to
walk
in severe pain really like really ill
and
it was just one of those things really
where i didn't expect ever to contract
meningitis didn't really have a clue
what it was so being able to now work
with meningitis now and to be able to
raise awareness on a campaign like this
is something that's really special to me
to be able to share
my story and kind of help people
know the signs and symptoms of what
meningitis actually is and that it can
affect anyone
yeah that sounds really scary as well
the fact that they
blue lit you or blue light what do you
say i don't know when in an ambulance
anyway um
as a result of your symptoms did you
recognize them did you know what was
happening to you did you link it to
meningitis no not at all so i i actually
had a rugby game that morning um and i
remember being saying to my mom i don't
want to let them down i want to go and
play rugby but i'm in so much pain
i thought the night before i just had
food poisoning i'd had spaghetti
bolognese so i was like oh maybe i maybe
i've undercooked something here but
actually it was the next morning when my
mom came home and said i've just looked
at your legs and you've got a little bit
of a rash um
that that could be something
that's kind of when we knew then that we
needed to get some some help um but yeah
the pain was unreal i remember saying to
the paramedics uh they said out of ten
how painful like how sore are you and i
said in all honesty i play rugby and
this is the most pain i've ever been in
so i think that's kind of the
realization and the other signs and
symptoms of the blotchy skin
and headaches stiff neck like that was
when it kind of all came together
so say that again blotchy skin
stiff neck talk us through the main
things to look out for so people are
aware yeah so there's a few uh key ones
in adults so it's blotchy skin
and stiff necks headaches fevers
vomiting
and you've obviously got the rash and
then one key way that you can check if
it is meningitis if the rash doesn't
disappear under a piece of glass under
the glass test and that's when you know
that you need to go and seek help um so
meningitis now do a really good really
good
um effort at
trying to educate people so that they do
know this and that it can happen to
anyone babies have a few different
symptoms but coming up um to union and
people going back to school and stuff
and being with around new people it's
really important to be able to pick up
on that and make sure that you help a
friend if there is anything like that
yeah and and
you know it
has really serious consequences in some
cases doesn't it so really good to be
aware
you're pushing this out as people can
head off to university
why that timing why is it so important
do you think at a time like this um so i
actually think i contracted meningitis
on one of my first uni nights out i just
joined new university for my fourth year
and i went out on a wednesday and i was
in hospital by the saturday
and unfortunately it's just one of those
areas where
lots of new people meeting each other
lots of different
people coming from different places a
lot of different bacteria in the air and
it's kind of one of those grounds where
um
a lot a lot of infection can can come
around pretty similar to covid so i
think in this time it's really important
that it's not you don't always just
think and assume that it's a hangover or
covid but also knowing that meningitis
is something that can affect anyone in
any at any age um is really important as
well
when you haven't got a mum with you like
you had you saw your rash and and uh
source advice very quick question about
vaccines there is a vaccine isn't there
can people just make sure that they've
got that before they head off yeah so i
had all my vaccines as a child and you
get them when you're younger and i think
you can also get boosters as well but
making sure that you ask us up to date
with all your vaccines and stuff
unfortunately sometimes you can just be
a carrier
and you can't avoid it but yeah i think
just making sure that you are trying to
be as healthy as you can and and
sticking with all all of your um
hospital records that will help but i
definitely was in hospital thinking that
i'd
accidentally missed a job but i hadn't i
was all up to date and unfortunately it
just uh was one of those things
right so well really useful advice this
morning rosie good see looking so fit
and well i know you've had ankle
problems which we can't go into i'm
sorry about that but um anyway we
appreciate your time this morning and
spreading the word about meningitis
thank you very much
thank you
now around one in five households in the
uk are private renters and with the cost
of living squeezing budgets rent really
is a growing concern well new figures
show that room rents are reaching an
all-time high in the biggest towns and
cities and now campaigners are calling
on the government
to introduce a cap on rental prices to
offer more protection for tenants dan
whitehead reports
for london tenant sarah paying her 700
pound room rent is already a struggle
this is my bedroom
my bed
i work in here as well i've got my desk
it uses up 60
of her monthly salary and like many in
the rental market she's facing a price
increase recently we our landlord has um
written to us saying he is increasing
the rent um
50 pounds per person per month
it doesn't sound a lot but when we're
already trying to scrape together the
rent as it is it is a lot of money to
add on top of that
sarah campaigns for the housing
organization acorn one of many groups
that wants to see more protection for
tenants
what we want to see is caps and rent
controls put in
we can't rely on landlords
to regulate themselves at the end of the
day they are business people and they
will take advantage of opportunities to
make as much profit as they can but a
cap on rent is not currently part of the
government's new renter's reform bill
which it says will create a fairer deal
for tenants the bill will offer more
protection banning things like no-fault
evictions and giving renters more power
to challenge poor housing conditions and
unjustified rent increases but campaign
groups say it doesn't go far enough
arvind has rented her room in bristol
for five years
the city has seen one of the biggest
leaps in room rental costs up more than
20 percent from the start of 2019.
i and millions in the same position as
me live with the constant fear you know
we're only one envelope away from being
unable to afford our rent that is just
the whim of a landlord there's nothing
to stop them from deciding they want
more money and increasing the rent at
any moment but organizations
representing landlords say increasing
rents is not a case of profiteering so i
wish it were as simple as landlords
getting greedy and deciding they want to
make more profit actually we're seeing
the opposite we're seeing our members
yield you know what their return on
investment go down because it's that
much more expensive to buy property it's
that much more expensive to run a
business so actually where we're seeing
the increases it's to cover things like
increased tax utility bills cost of
management it's not because they're
protecting a margin there are 4.4
million private renters in the uk
with energy bills set to rise again this
autumn they are looking for even more
protection to ensure the homes they have
stay affordable
tom whitehead sky news in bristol
let's take a look now what the weather's
up to this weekend
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
well the weekend will bring fresher
conditions with showers or longer spells
of rain especially in the north and the
west southeastern parts are mainly fine
but there are some showers elsewhere
with more general heavy rain in the
windy north coastal gales are possible
in the far northwest
a narrow band of heavy rain and gusty
winds will largely clear the rest of
scotland and northern ireland during the
morning while spreading across more of
ireland brighter more showery conditions
will follow on further south it'll stay
mainly dry
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
well it's time to delve into the papers
again this morning here with me to
review them are the journalists and
broadcaster bedisha mamata and the
editor of spiked magazine tom slater
into their third round doing really well
still with us which is great
badisha we're going to kick off with you
um a story that's on the front page of
the times today but has also made it as
you spotted inside the sun here um
michael gove uh some would call him a
big beast of the tory party i think he
qualifies for that description uh he is
backing rishi sunak in in the race for
the leadership
yes i don't think big beast is a
misplaced term he is one of the sort of
mid or pre-pandemic big names that you'd
hear about in the headlines all the time
he's come out to punt for rishi sinha
against tory leadership rival liz truss
and he said that trust has in fact taken
a holiday from reality now he's not
saying that she's gone crackers or
anything like that but what he is saying
is that she is
neglecting the needs of the poorest and
most vulnerable in society because her
prose e her proposed economic plans
really only tackle those who are already
rich so she's proposed changes to
corporation tax and national insurance
and she's rejected what she calls
further handouts but uh gov is saying
that look this doesn't get anywhere near
the biting point of the coming recession
the cost of living crisis and all the
multiple the omni shambles of
deprivation and inequality economically
that we're currently suffering it's
interesting that he would then back
rishi sunak because rishi sanak is
this is a phrase which is not often used
of him the underdog in this race because
trust is really pulling ahead to the
lead but the other interesting thing
about michael gove's article in the
times is
he's slipped in a rather plangent
melancholic side note which is pointing
out that he doesn't expect to be in
government again that he's enjoyed 11
years in the cabinet under three prime
ministers so
in a sense he's taking a back seat a
backbencher seat perhaps and stepping
away from the fray the rough and tumble
now in the extent of a career 11 years
doesn't sound like a very long time to
have a career but it's a very long time
in politics that does qualify him for
big beast rhinoceros or elephant status
in terms of political animology shall we
say we've all got fabulous images in our
mind now thank you for that video let's
move on to a different issue shall we
tom
and it's one that's we've been focusing
on a lot in recent weeks and it's about
water firms while
many areas are being told they can't use
their hose pipes at the moment because
of drought conditions
a lot of focus
on water firms and how much they're
doing about it so what's this article
tell us
so these are figures from water leakage
from the water firms last year and they
lost a trillion liters via leaky pipes
over the course of the pasture that
equates to about almost half a million
olympic sized swimming pools and given
the fact that as you were saying there
was there's these hose pipe bands which
are being announced um across the
country there are various different
parts of the country which have been
said to be technically in drought at
this point
this i think is going to make a lot of
people wonder why they're being asked to
limit their usage when the water
companies themselves seem incapable of
stemming these kinds of leaks apparently
the worst defender here is thames water
and of course that hose pipe band for
the 10 water areas coming in
this week in particular and i feel like
when it comes to the water companies as
it does with various other even private
sector companies in this case or just
other kind of essential services whether
they're in public or private hands this
kind of sense that the service is
getting worse and worse that we're being
asked time and time again to kind of
manage our own usage of those services
in order to keep things ticking over and
then and yet you see this kind of rank
incompetence across the piece there's
this story about the water companies
there's another story about the water
companies in the news which i don't want
to mention because probably put a lot of
people off their breakfast in relation
to some of the things which have been on
earth but this again i think is just
that kind of sense in which
that pervading sense we have in this
country at the moment that just nothing
is working particularly well and that
whilst um again we're seeing
increasing inabilities to deliver us
these um services we're being asked to
give up more and more that seems to be
the picture that's um that's forming a
lot in people's minds tom thank you for
your sensitivity towards our sensitive
tummies at this time of the morning i
have no idea what you're talking about
but i dread to think um but um but i
didn't notice you nodding your head
there i mean this is an issue that kind
of
really annoys people is isn't it this
issue of of water companies apparently
not doing their bit is it a fair
criticism
i think it is a fair criticism in the
sense that whenever we ourselves the
citizens are being asked to do something
in order to solve what is essentially an
infrastructure problem it's very natural
to turn your
chagrin your frustration your eye back
on the companies and say well you're
asking us to be perfect and by the way i
completely agree with the host pipe ban
and the water limitation advice but we
then ask the companies well what are you
doing you're putting this on us but have
you been really perfect all the way
through so i think that's a natural
tendency to look for a little bit of a
scapegoat i do really hear what tom's
saying however about that quality of
god is nothing working
all these different systems and
structures and infrastructures in
various different unrelated fields are
being looked at with scrutiny and being
found wanting so that for me is the
takeaway this idea that we are arriving
at a moment of crisis exactly when
ordinary people and ordinary families
are so hard pressed
to do things themselves that relieve
these various pressures on top of
contending with recession inflation
stalled wages
cost of living crisis energy prices and
all the rest of it so the sense of
anxiety is the thing that i really hear
uh
i'm going to move us on to to other
issues and partly tom i've noticed
you've picked out a story in the times
and it says
orwell's ideal pub could be closed down
and i read through it and i thought i
know that bob
it's a very nice pop but anyway tell me
tell me the story
yes so this is the copton arms in
islington um which is a really historic
pub it's been open since the 1800s and
it was quite frequented i should say by
george orwell he actually
wrote an essay once in the evening in
1946
describing his kind of ideal fictional
pub called the moon underwater which is
in large part based on the content of
this particular pub
it's been subject to a license review
because of four neighbors it turns out
who have complained about noise and
disruption they've deemed it a public
nuisance um despite the fact that this
was quite recently named one of the best
pubs in the country so the idea is kind
of you know fallen under crazy ownership
and it's you know become a bit of a
blight on the area it doesn't seem to
stack up this is a increasing picture we
see particularly in london but across
our cities as well
where you essentially have just people
kind of moving into the area and then
being surprised that they're next to
pubs and nightclubs in this particular
case apparently the landlord has pointed
out that a lot of people kind of got
used to the quiet of lockdown and are
now shocked to find that people are out
enjoying themselves and i think it's
just one you know we've seen loads of
venues closed in recent years loads of
pubs closed particularly because of the
pressures of the lockdown and you know i
think this is an example that you're not
just
losing a a great place to go and have a
drink you're often losing a piece of
history um because of the fact that a
few people
again are surprised to realize that the
pub they moved in across from is
actually open from time to time so yeah
a sad sign of the times and that's it
indeed and very interesting i had no
idea about that history and badisha
about two hours ago i promised you that
we would come back to an article you
chose and we didn't have time for about
house of the dragon we're at that moment
take it away
okay everybody if you like
boobs and bums and poisonings and
murders and stabbings and dragons and
some really impressive wig acting where
the weeks are really carrying the scene
tomorrow on hbo and related channels
house of the dragon based on the game of
thrones prequel written by george r r
martin
in a side note from making squazillions
of pounds is launching it tells the
story of if you're not a game of thrones
flat fan uh the blonde ones that's all
you need to know they were bloody they
were incestuous they were violent they
were very ambitious just like all the
families in game of thrones and now you
can watch their entire saga i've already
read the reviews of the first couple of
episodes and it does indeed promise lots
of all the stuff you loved and hated and
hated to love and love to hate about the
original series don't expect subtlety
don't expect to be able to follow the
plot after about six episodes do just
sit back and enjoy the fabulous costumes
and all the uh
all the stuff we have to leave it there
but i really enjoyed that burst of
enthusiasm we saw from you there i've
got to say goodbye to both of you thanks
both very much
[Music]